y nos preguntan cuáles dos de las
siguientes expresiones tienen el mismo
valor que 8.76 pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta
ahora vamos a resolverlo juntos y antes
de ver las opciones quiero comprender
bien a qué se refiere esta cantidad
vamos a reescribir lo tenemos 8.76 hay
un par de formas de pensar en esto
podemos ver el valor posicional aquí
está la posición de las unidades esta es
la posición de las décimas y esta otra
es la posición de las centésimas podemos
ver esto como ocho unidades siete
décimas y seis centésimas y ocho
unidades más siete décimas más seis
centésimas esto es exactamente lo que
está en la primera opción ocho unidades
más siete décimas más seis centésimas
así que esta es una opción correcta
la segunda opción luce como una forma
extendida pero antes de analizarla
veamos cómo se vería esta de arriba si
queremos escribir la misma idea
forma extendida es 8 unidades es lo
mismo que 8 por 1 de hecho vamos a
codificar esto con colores para saber de
dónde viene cada cosa a esto le sumamos
7 décimas que es 7 por una décima son
siete décimas vamos a usar este color
anaranjado seis centésimas que es seis
por una centésima seis centésimas este
número en forma extendida es igual a lo
que está en la segunda opción por lo que
también elegimos esta opción si hicieran
esto por su cuenta ya sabrían que
eligieron las dos opciones pero veamos
si podemos escribir esto en estos
formatos para ver por qué éstas no son
las opciones correctas si escribimos
esto descomponiéndolo en sus partes
decimales las ocho unidades se escriben
como ocho las siete décimas se escriben
como 0.7 que son siete décimas esta
parte esto y estos son equivalentes y
por último pero no menos importante
tenemos seis centésimas las escribimos
como cero unidades cero décimas
en la posición de las centésimas
escribimos 6 esto es equivalente al
número original pero no es lo que está
en esta opción aquí escribieron 8
unidades
aquí escribieron 7 décimas pero no
escribieron 6 centésimas sino que
escribieron 6 milésimas así que
descartamos esta opción y si
escribiéramos este número con palabras
quedaría 8 y usamos otro color podemos
poner siete décimas y seis centésimas o
podríamos como normalmente se hace
expresar lo en términos de la posición
de menor valor o de la posición más
precisa que tengamos podemos ver siete
décimas como 70 centésimas o podemos ver
todo esto como 76 centésimas por lo que
podemos escribirlo como 8 y 76
centésimas pero lo que escribieron aquí
es 8 y 67 centésimas en lugar de 8 y 76
centésimas esto pudo habernos confundido
descartamos esta opción